Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky BBQ glaze and topped with a creamy BBQ sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. On Thursday, January 17, 2008, Rick Goff placed a call to his 21-year-old daughter, Denise Amber Lee. He wanted to invite Denise, her husband Nathan, and their two young sons over for dinner that night. Denise didn't answer, so Rick left her a voicemail. As at near 4pm, Rick's cell phone rang. It was his son-in-law, Nathan Lee. Rick figured Nathan was calling to accept the dinner invitation. He was shocked instead to hear Nathan say, Denise is missing. The weather on Florida's west coast was warm that day. In the city of Northport, a few miles inland from Venice Beach, 23-year-old Nathan Lee was with his son-in-law. At 11am, he called home to speak to his wife, Denise. Given they were on a tight budget, Nathan asked Denise to open the windows instead of turning on the air conditioning. Denise reassured him that she already had. As 3pm near and Nathan's shift was ending, he called Denise again. She didn't pick up. Nathan tried eight more times during the 25-minute drive home, but Denise never answered. Although unusual, Nathan assumed Denise was just busy. It wasn't until he pulled up at their house that he sensed something wasn't right.
你试过在烧烤上吃烧烤吗？想象一下：新鲜烹制的酥脆调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉，再淋上奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来？那你现在就可以去蒂姆餐厅尝尝。限时供应我们全新的烧烤脆皮鸡肉碗和卷饼。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序或我们网站上本集的节目说明。2008年1月17日星期四，里克·戈夫给21岁的女儿丹妮丝·安布尔·李打了个电话。他想邀请丹妮丝、她的丈夫内森以及他们的两个年幼儿子当晚过来吃晚饭。丹妮丝没有接听，所以里克给她留了语音留言。下午4点左右，里克的手机响了。是他的女婿内森·李。里克以为内森是打电话来接受晚餐邀请的。然而，当听到内森说“丹妮丝失踪了”时，他震惊不已。那天佛罗里达西海岸的天气很暖和。在距离威尼斯海滩内陆几英里的北港市，23岁的内森·李和他的女婿在一起。上午11点，他打电话回家和妻子丹妮丝说话。由于手头拮据，内森让丹妮丝打开窗户，而不是开空调。丹妮丝向他保证她已经打开了。下午3点临近，内森的轮班即将结束，他又给丹妮丝打了电话。她没有接。在回家的25分钟车程中，内森又试了八次，但丹妮丝始终没有接听。虽然不寻常，但内森以为丹妮丝只是在忙。直到他把车停在自家门口，才感觉到有些不对劲。
All of the windows were closed. The front door was locked. After entering, Nathan heard his two-year-old and six-month-old sons. He found them in their bedroom, sitting up in the same crib. Denise didn't typically put the boys in bed together. She was also an attentive mother, yet both boys' diapers were soiled. Nathan searched the house for Denise, but she was nowhere to be found. While everything appeared in place, Nathan soon discovered that the windows had only been pushed closed, not latched and locked like the front door. Denise was security-conscious. She wouldn't leave the house accessible if she had to hurry out for some reason, nor would she have left her young sons alone. Nathan called 911 to report his wife is missing. He then called Denise's father, Rick Goff.
所有的窗户都关着。前门锁着。进入屋内后，内森听到了他两岁和六个月大儿子的声音。他在卧室里发现了他们，两人坐在同一个婴儿床里。丹妮丝通常不会把两个孩子放在一起睡觉。她也是一位细心的母亲，但两个孩子的尿布都脏了。内森在屋里寻找丹妮丝，但她不见踪影。虽然一切看起来都很正常，但内森很快发现窗户只是被推上了，并没有像前门那样扣好锁上。丹妮丝很有安全意识。如果她因为某种原因匆忙出门，她不会让房子处于不设防的状态，也不会把年幼的儿子独自留在家里。内森拨打911报告妻子失踪。随后他给丹妮丝的父亲里克·戈夫打了电话。
Rick was a 25-year law enforcement veteran and currently worked in a neighboring county as a sheriff's lieutenant. He knew that when someone goes missing, the first person of interest was almost always their spouse. Yet, he firmly believed Nathan Lee had nothing to do with his daughter's disappearance. The young couple had been head over heels in love since meeting at community college. Within weeks of their first date, Nathan bought Denise a silver ring with a heart on it for Valentine's Day. She never took it off, not even after receiving her engagement ring years later. Nathan and Denise were raising their boys in North Port Estates, a new housing development in a relatively rural, isolated area. Rick Goff hadn't been thrilled when his daughter and her husband moved to the property.
里克是一名有25年经验的执法老兵，目前在邻县担任警长中尉。他知道，当有人失踪时，第一个被怀疑的对象几乎总是他们的配偶。然而，他坚信内森·李与他女儿的失踪无关。这对年轻夫妇自社区大学相识以来就一直深爱着对方。第一次约会后的几周内，内森就给丹妮丝买了一枚带有心形图案的银戒指作为情人节礼物。她从未摘下过它，即使在多年后收到订婚戒指时也是如此。内森和丹妮丝在北港庄园抚养他们的孩子，这是一个位于相对偏远、孤立地区的住宅开发项目。里克·戈夫对女儿和女婿搬到那里并不感到高兴。
He thought it felt a bit like a ghost town. But the three-bedroom house was brand new and the rent was affordable. Until recently, Nathan had to juggle three jobs to support their growing family. Denise stayed home to raise the boys, putting her college ambitions temporarily on hold. Police arrived at the Lee's rental house on La Tour Avenue. There were no signs of forced entry or foul play and nothing had been stolen or displaced. Denise's purse, keys, car and cell phone were all at the house. With no indication as to where she might have gone, police officers began door knocking the Lee's neighbors for information.
他觉得那里有点像鬼城。但那栋三居室的房子是全新的，租金也很实惠。直到最近，内森还不得不打三份工来维持他们日益增长的家庭开支。丹妮丝留在家里照顾孩子，暂时搁置了她的大学梦想。警察抵达了李家位于拉图尔大道的出租屋。没有强行闯入或犯罪的迹象，也没有任何东西被盗或移动。丹妮丝的钱包、钥匙、汽车和手机都在屋里。由于没有任何线索表明她可能去了哪里，警察开始敲邻居的门询问信息。
Jennifer was a teenager who'd been staying with relatives one house over from the Lee's. That afternoon, she'd been in a front room watching television. At around 2pm, Jennifer's attention was drawn to a window that overlooked the quiet street. A car was slowly cruising up and down La Tour Avenue. As if its driver was looking for a specific address. When the car passed by a fourth or fifth time, Jennifer went outside to see if the driver was lost. Just as Jennifer exited the house, the car pulled into Nathan and Denise Lee's driveway. Jennifer made eye contact with the driver, who'd been in contact with the driver.
詹妮弗是一个十几岁的女孩，一直住在李家隔壁的亲戚家。那天下午，她一直在前厅看电视。下午2点左右，詹妮弗的注意力被一扇俯瞰安静街道的窗户吸引了。一辆车正缓慢地在拉图尔大道上来回行驶。好像司机在寻找特定的地址。当这辆车第四或第五次经过时，詹妮弗走到外面看看司机是不是迷路了。就在詹妮弗走出房子时，那辆车开进了内森和丹妮丝·李家的车道。詹妮弗与司机进行了眼神交流。
He was white with a heavy set face, light coloured eyes and a blondish hair. Jennifer returned home, assuming the man was a friend of the Lee's. The car remained parked in the Lee's driveway. Jennifer never saw anyone get in or out of the vehicle. About 10 minutes later, the car was parked in the Lee's driveway. Jennifer never saw anyone get in or out of the vehicle. About 10 to 15 minutes later, at around 2.30pm, she noticed it driving away. This encounter occurred an hour before Nathan Lee returned home from work to discover Denise had vanished.
他是个白人，脸型宽大，浅色眼睛，留着金发。詹妮弗回到家，以为那个人是李家的朋友。那辆车一直停在李家的车道上。詹妮弗从未看到有人上车或下车。大约10分钟后，那辆车停在李家的车道上。詹妮弗从未看到有人上车或下车。大约10到15分钟后，即下午2点30分左右，她注意到它开走了。这次相遇发生在该内森·李下班回家发现丹妮丝失踪前的一个小时。
A bulletin was issued asking all police officers in the area to be on the lookout for the car Jennifer had witnessed. A two-door 1990s model Chevrolet Camaro. It was dark green with a protective black vinyl or leather casing attached to its front, known as a cabra. Wasting little time, police informed locals and the media of the situation to bolster their chances of finding the Camaro. Entrance ramps to the Interstate 75 highway were monitored to prevent the suspect vehicle from fleeing North Port if it hadn't already. Highway patrol officers stopped traffic to conduct on-the-spot vehicle inspections. A search helicopter swept overhead while police dogs were used to scour the land below. Authorities in neighboring counties pulled their resources to help find Denise as she was the daughter of one of their own.
警方发布了一份公告，要求该地区的所有警察留意詹妮弗目击到的那辆车。一辆1990年代的双门雪佛兰科迈罗。它是深绿色的，车头装有一个保护性的黑色乙烯基或皮革外壳，被称为“卡布拉”。警方争分夺秒，将情况告知当地居民和媒体，以增加找到这辆科迈罗的机会。75号州际公路的入口匝道受到监控，以防止嫌疑车辆在尚未离开的情况下逃离北港。公路巡警拦截车辆进行现场检查。一架搜救直升机在空中盘旋，同时警犬被用来搜寻地面。邻县的当局调动资源协助寻找丹妮丝，因为她是他们自己人中的一员。
Even federal law enforcement assisted in the investigation. Then, at 6.14pm, a call came through to 911. A panicked woman on the other line cried out, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I just want to go. The dispatcher tried to communicate with the caller, repeating the word hello several times. But the woman ignored her, instead talking to someone else nearby. It was a man. Why did you do that? he asked.
甚至联邦执法部门也协助了调查。然后，在下午6点14分，911接到一个电话。电话那头一个惊慌失措的女人哭喊道：“对不起，对不起，我只想走。”调度员试图与来电者沟通，重复了几次“喂”。但那个女人无视了她，转而与附近的人交谈。那是个男人。“你为什么要那样做？”他问。
The woman continued to apologize. She begged to be released and see her family. It sounded as though she and the man were in a moving vehicle. Her radio was playing music loudly in the background, making it difficult to hear what was going on. The dispatcher continued to ask questions which went ignored. The woman repeatedly begged to be let go. The man retorted, I was gonna let you go, then you go fuck around.
那个女人继续道歉。她恳求被释放并见见她的家人。听起来她和那个男人在一辆行驶的车辆中。她的收音机在背景中大声播放着音乐，让人很难听清发生了什么。调度员继续问问题，但都被忽略了。那个女人反复恳求被放走。那个男人反驳道：“我本来打算放你走的，结果你却乱搞。”
He complained about having to drive a different route because she had done something, quote, in front of my cousin Harold. The dispatcher asked for an address while simultaneously putting a trace on the call. The woman asked the man where they were going. Didn't you see, the man responded. Exactly four streets, well five streets over from your house. The phone pinged off the North Port cell phone tower. The dispatcher asked for the woman's name.
他抱怨说不得不走另一条路，因为她做了某事，引用他的话，“在我的表弟哈罗德面前”。调度员要求提供地址，同时对电话进行追踪。那个女人问那个男人他们要去哪里。“你没看见吗？”那个男人回答道。“就在你家隔开四条街，哦不，五条街的地方。”电话信号定位到了北港的手机信号塔。调度员询问那个女人的名字。
Please, my name is Denise, I'm married to a beautiful husband and I just want to see my kids again, she stated. It appeared as though she could hear the dispatcher, but had made the call discreetly and didn't want the man to realize. Her responses were phrased to mislead the man into thinking she was talking to him directly. What's your last name, the dispatcher asked. The woman responded, Lee. The man then seemingly caught on to the deception. He suddenly asked, what did you do with my cell phone? The car's radio stopped.
“求你了，我叫丹妮丝，我有一个很棒的丈夫，我只想再见到我的孩子们，”她说。看起来她能听到调度员的声音，但她是悄悄拨打的电话，不想让那个男人察觉。她的回答措辞是为了误导那个男人，让他以为她在直接对他说话。“你姓什么？”调度员问。那个女人回答：“李。”那个男人似乎识破了骗局。他突然问：“你对我的手机做了什么？”车里的收音机停了。
Right before the call abruptly disconnected, the woman was heard asking the man. The call lasted almost six minutes. Given Denise Lee's case was receiving wide-scale media and police attention, the possibility the call was a hoax was considered. The recording was played to Rick Goff, who immediately asked for the man's name. The call lasted almost six minutes. Unfortunately, the call was a hoax was considered. The recording was played to Rick Goff, who immediately identified the female caller as his daughter.
在电话突然断开之前，那个女人被听到在问那个男人。通话持续了近六分钟。鉴于丹妮丝·李的案件受到了媒体和警方的广泛关注，人们考虑了该电话是恶作剧的可能性。录音被播放给里克·戈夫听，他立即询问那个男人的名字。通话持续了近六分钟。不幸的是，人们考虑了该电话是恶作剧的可能性。录音被播放给里克·戈夫听，他立即认出那个女来电者是他的女儿。
While devastating to hear her in trouble, the call offered Denise's loved ones a glimmer of hope. She was still alive. Authorities tried to trace the call, but it had been made using a cheap, prepaid phone. This meant it wasn't fitted with a GPS tracking device that investigators could use to pinpoint the phone's exact location. They could only uncover which towers it had pinged. However, they were able to identify the phone's owner via its number. It belonged to a 36-year-old unemployed plumber named Michael King. King had no criminal record aside from a few traffic fines.
虽然听到她陷入困境令人心碎，但这个电话给了丹妮丝的亲人一丝希望。她还活着。当局试图追踪电话，但它是用一部廉价的预付费手机拨打的。这意味着它没有配备调查人员可以用来精确定位手机确切位置的GPS追踪装置。他们只能查出它连接了哪些信号塔。然而，他们能够通过号码识别出手机的主人。它属于一名36岁、失业的管道工，名叫迈克尔·金。金除了几张交通罚单外，没有犯罪记录。
The name meant nothing to Denise's family. They had no idea who Michael King was and couldn't imagine why he would target Denise. Harold Muxlow lived on Carlec Street, about four miles south of the Lee's home. He was completely unaware of the investigation unfolding nearby. Sometime between 5.30 and 6.00 pm, Harold heard a knock at his front door. It was his cousin, 36-year-old Michael King. Michael explained that his lawn mower had become stuck in his yard and he needed some equipment to dig it out. He asked to borrow a shovel, a gas can and a flashlight.
这个名字对丹妮丝的家人来说毫无意义。他们不知道迈克尔·金是谁，也无法想象他为什么要针对丹妮丝。哈罗德·马克斯洛住在卡莱克街，距离李家以南约四英里。他完全不知道附近正在进行的调查。下午5点30分到6点之间，哈罗德听到有人敲前门。是他的表弟，36岁的迈克尔·金。迈克尔解释说他的割草机卡在院子里了，需要一些工具把它挖出来。他借了一把铲子、一个汽油桶和一把手电筒。
Harold invited Michael inside. The two men chatted for a while before Harold handed the tools over. Michael then carried them over to his green Chevrolet Camaro and said goodbye to his cousin. As Harold turned to walk back inside, he heard a woman's voice scream, called the cops. The plea had come from inside Michael's vehicle. Harold spun around. What the fuck are you doing? He asked Michael. Nothing, his cousin replied. Don't worry about it.
哈罗德请迈克尔进屋。两人聊了一会儿，哈罗德把工具交给了他。迈克尔随后把它们搬到他的绿色雪佛兰科迈罗上，并向他的表弟告别。当哈罗德转身走回屋里时，他听到一个女人的声音尖叫道：“报警！”这个请求来自迈克尔的车内。哈罗德猛地转过身。“你到底在干什么？”他问迈克尔。“没什么，”他表弟回答。“别担心。”
Don't worry about it. Harold figured Michael was having an argument with a girlfriend. Michael had been known to have some tempestuous relationships since his marriage ended almost seven years earlier. Harold began to walk towards his house, but his curiosity got the better of him. He turned around and headed back down the driveway towards Michael's car. He could see a female silhouette with shoulder length hair in the back seat. It was too dim to see any of her other features. Michael had clambered into the car and was crawling over the console.
“别担心。”哈罗德以为迈克尔在和女朋友吵架。众所周知，自七年前婚姻结束以来，迈克尔有一些动荡的关系。哈罗德开始朝他的房子走去，但好奇心战胜了他。他转过身，沿着车道朝迈克尔的车走去。他可以看到后座上有一个留着齐肩长发的女性轮廓。光线太暗，看不清她的其他特征。迈克尔爬进车里，正爬过中控台。
He pushed the woman's head down so she was out of sight. One of the woman's knees rose up as though she was struggling against Michael. Michael then climbed back into the driver's seat, started the engine and drove away. Harold Muxlow wasn't sure what to do. He wasn't certain that anything was seriously wrong, but the incident didn't sit right with him. He decided to drive over to Michael's house to see if his story checked out. If he found Michael there and the lawnmower was indeed stuck in his yard, then Harold would know his cousin had been telling the truth. Michael only lived about six miles away in another part of Northport, so it didn't take Harold long to drive over.
他把那个女人的头按下去，让她看不见。那个女人的膝盖抬了起来，好像在和迈克尔挣扎。迈克尔随后爬回驾驶座，发动引擎开走了。哈罗德·马克斯洛不知道该怎么办。他不确定是否真的出了什么严重的问题，但这件事让他感觉不对劲。他决定开车去迈克尔家看看他的说法是否属实。如果他在那里找到了迈克尔，而且割草机确实卡在院子里，那么哈罗德就会知道他表弟说的是实话。迈克尔只住在约六英里外的北港另一部分，所以哈罗德没花多久就开车到了那里。
Michael's Camaro wasn't parked in the driveway, and when Harold rang the doorbell, no one answered. There wasn't a lawnmower in sight. Harold was reluctant to alert the authorities. Instead, he phoned his 17-year-old daughter Sabrina and informed her of what had taken place. Harold told Sabrina not to call the police, but as soon as they entered their call, Sabrina didn't hesitate. She phoned 911 at 6.23pm, just minutes after the frantic call placed by Denise Lee. Realising the significance of Sabrina's call, the dispatcher said, You are just so wonderful to call us and give us this information.
迈克尔的科迈罗没有停在车道上，当哈罗德按门铃时，没有人回答。视线内没有割草机。哈罗德不愿惊动当局。相反，他给17岁的女儿萨布丽娜打了电话，告诉她发生了什么事。哈罗德告诉萨布丽娜不要报警，但他们刚挂断电话，萨布丽娜就毫不犹豫地拨打了911，时间是下午6点23分，就在丹妮丝·李拨出那个疯狂电话的几分钟后。意识到萨布丽娜电话的重要性，调度员说：“你打电话给我们并提供这些信息真是太棒了。”
Sabrina didn't know where Michael King might have taken Denise, but investigators now knew for certain that he was behind the abduction. Based on the items he had borrowed from his cousin, they also realised that time was of the essence. By now, the sun was setting over Northport. Towards the city south, a woman named Jane Kowalski was driving south along US Highway 41. She came to a stop at a traffic light. While waiting for it to turn green, Jane suddenly heard a horrific high-pitched scream. It had come from the car in the lane next to Jane's. It was a dark-coloured Camaro.
萨布丽娜不知道迈克尔·金可能把丹妮丝带到了哪里，但调查人员现在确定他就是绑架案的幕后黑手。根据他从表弟那里借来的物品，他们也意识到时间紧迫。此时，太阳正在北港落下。在城市南边，一个名叫简·科瓦尔斯基的女人正沿着41号美国国道向南行驶。她在红绿灯处停了下来。在等待绿灯时，简突然听到一声可怕的尖叫声。声音来自简旁边车道上的车。那是一辆深色的科迈罗。
Jane made eye contact with the Camaro's male driver and gave him a quizzical look, as though to ask what was going on. He was using one hand to push something down the road. A small hand then stretched up from the back seat and began frantically hitting the passenger window, trying to get attention. Jane believed she might have been witnessing a child abduction. As the traffic light turned green, she drove to the back seat. Jane was in the back seat of the passenger window, trying to get attention. She had been witnessing a child abduction. As the traffic light turned green, she drove forward slowly so that she would be able to see the Camaro's license plate as it passed her.
简与科迈罗的男司机进行了眼神交流，并给了他一个困惑的表情，好像在问发生了什么事。他正用一只手把什么东西推向路边。一只小手随后从后座伸出来，疯狂地拍打着乘客侧的车窗，试图引起注意。简认为她可能目睹了一起儿童绑架案。当红绿灯变绿时，她开车到后座。简在乘客侧车窗的后座，试图引起注意。她目睹了一起儿童绑架案。当红绿灯变绿时，她缓慢向前行驶，以便在科迈罗经过她时能看到它的车牌。
But the driver seemed to know that she was still watching, and he drove slowly too. He then changed into her lane so he was driving directly behind Jane. As the Camaro only had a license plate on the rear, Jane couldn't see it as long as it stayed back. Realising the driver wasn't going to let her see his license plate, Jane dialed 911 on her cellphone. It was exactly 6.30pm, mere minutes after they had received the calls from Denise Lee and Sabrina Moxlow. When an operator answered, Jane immediately began providing a description of the incident, along with up-to-date details about her location. She was driving just 45mph. The Camaro continued to creep along even more slowly behind her. The two vehicles were holding up their entire lane of traffic.
但司机似乎知道她还在看着，他也开得很慢。然后他换到了她的车道，直接开在简的后面。由于科迈罗只有后部有车牌，只要它保持在后面，简就看不见。意识到司机不会让她看到他的车牌，简用手机拨打了911。时间正好是下午6点30分，距离他们接到丹妮丝·李和萨布丽娜·马克斯洛的电话仅几分钟。当接线员接听时，简立即开始提供事件的描述，以及她所在位置的最新细节。她正以每小时45英里的速度行驶。科迈罗继续在她后面更慢地爬行。这两辆车堵住了整条车道。
Even though Jane believed the victim was a child and described the Camaro as blue instead of green, the operator knew they had another eyewitness to the Denise Lee abduction. She called out the information to someone else in the centre, as Jane provided updates about the Camaro's movements. Suddenly, the Camaro swerved and pulled into a lane that was turning off the highway and left onto Toledo Blade Boulevard. Jane asked if she should follow it. By the time the operator asked if she was able to, there was too much other traffic in the way. The Camaro had turned and Jane could no longer see the vehicle. Despite numerous patrol cars circling the area where the Camaro was last seen, none of them spotted the vehicle. At 6.50pm, another tip-off was made to 911 via a payphone. Harold Moxlow had a change of heart and decided to anonymously report what had happened earlier with his cousin.
尽管简认为受害者是个孩子，并将科迈罗描述为蓝色而不是绿色，但接线员知道他们有了丹妮丝·李绑架案的另一名目击者。她向中心里的其他人喊出了这些信息，同时简提供了关于科迈罗动向的最新情况。突然，科迈罗转向并驶入了一条离开高速公路的车道，向左转到了托莱多刀锋大道。简问她是否应该跟上去。当接线员问她是否能跟上时，路上已经有太多其他车辆了。科迈罗转弯了，简再也看不见那辆车了。尽管有无数巡逻车在科迈罗最后出现的地方盘旋，但没有一辆车发现它。下午6点50分，有人通过公用电话向911提供了另一条线索。哈罗德·马克斯洛改变了主意，决定匿名报告早些时候他表弟发生的事情。
By this time, investigators were well aware of Michael King's involvement in the Denise Lee abduction. By now, she had been gone for roughly four hours. Armed with a search warrant, they arrived at King's residence on Sardinia Avenue. It was a modest single-story home with a large garage and a wide driveway. King's Camaro wasn't parked outside, but police officers could hear voices coming from inside the house. They gained access and were confronted with the barely lived-in sparsely furnished space. The voices officers heard emanated from a television that blared from the front room. In the kitchen, a roll of silver-coloured duct tape was lying on a counter.
此时，调查人员已经非常清楚迈克尔·金参与了丹妮丝·李的绑架案。到目前为止，她已经失踪了大约四个小时。带着搜查令，他们抵达了金位于萨丁尼亚大道的住所。这是一栋朴素的单层住宅，带有一个大车库和宽阔的车道。金的科迈罗没有停在外面，但警察能听到屋里传出声音。他们进入屋内，面对的是一个几乎没人住、家具稀疏的空间。警察听到的声音来自前厅里大声播放的电视。在厨房里，一卷银色的胶带放在柜台上。
A garbage bag in the pantry had some pieces of duct tape in it, with long, light-brown hairs stuck to the adhesive. The dining room featured several rectangular mirrors hanging side-by-side on a wall. Then, there was one empty set of hooks. It appeared one mirror had been removed. It was found in the main bedroom, where a clock radio was also switched on and blasting music. The mirror was propped against a wall. Directly across from the mirror, a Winnie the Pooh blanket lay on the floor along with some pillows. A second yellow blanket had been draped over the bedroom window.
食品储藏室里的一个垃圾袋里有一些胶带碎片，粘合剂上粘着长长的浅棕色头发。餐厅的墙上挂着几面长方形的镜子，并排悬挂。然后，有一组空挂钩。看起来有一面镜子被取走了。它在主卧室被发现，那里的一台时钟收音机也开着，播放着音乐。镜子靠在墙上。在镜子的正对面，一条小熊维尼毯子和一些枕头躺在地板上。第二条黄色毯子披在卧室窗户上。
Also on the floor was a wadded-up strip of duct tape with more light-brown hairs attached. Swabs taken from the end of the duct tape matched Michael King's DNA profile. The hairs belonged to Denise Lee. The Winnie the Pooh blanket featured semen stains that tested positive for King's DNA as well. There was blood on the blanket too. Obtaining a DNA profile for it proved difficult, but Denise couldn't be excluded from the result. Despite these key findings, neither Denise Lee or Michael King were found at the property. The search continued.
地板上还有一团粘着更多浅棕色头发的胶带。从胶带末端提取的拭子与迈克尔·金的DNA图谱相符。头发属于丹妮丝·李。小熊维尼毯子上有精液污渍，经检测也呈金的DNA阳性。毯子上还有血迹。获取其DNA图谱很困难，但丹妮丝无法从结果中排除。尽管有这些关键发现，但在该房产中既没有找到丹妮丝·李，也没有找到迈克尔·金。搜寻工作继续进行。
A statewide alert was issued as petrol stations were checked to see if anyone matching King's description had filled a gas tank that night. Surveillance footage was obtained, but didn't provide any leads. Police continued to comb the streets looking for King's Green Camaro. Deputy Christian Weimer and State Trooper Edward Pope were monitoring Toledo Blade Boulevard, the street that witnessed Jane Kowalski had seen the Camaro turn onto two and a half hours earlier. They were stationed near the turnoff to Interstate 75 Highway. At 9.10pm they spotted a 1995 Green Camaro that matched Michael King's, right down to the black cabra attached to the front. It was headed for the on-ramp of Interstate 75 Southbound. State Trooper Pope took off after the vehicle.
警方发布了全州警报，检查加油站，看那天晚上是否有人符合金的描述加过油。获得了监控录像，但没有提供任何线索。警察继续梳理街道，寻找金的绿色科迈罗。克里斯蒂安·威默副警长和爱德华·波普州警正在监控托莱多刀锋大道，也就是简·科瓦尔斯基目击到科迈罗在两个半小时前转入的那条街。他们驻扎在靠近75号州际公路的出口附近。晚上9点10分，他们发现了一辆1995年的绿色科迈罗，与迈克尔·金的车相符，连车头安装的黑色卡布拉都一模一样。它正驶向75号州际公路南向的入口匝道。州警波普追赶那辆车。
Its license plate matched King's. Turning on his car's lights and sirens, Pope forced the Camaro to pull over. Pope exited his own vehicle and got out his gun. He ordered the Camaro's driver to step out of the car. The driver ignored him. Pope repeated the order four more times, but the driver didn't budge. Pope repeated himself yet again. Finally, the driver's side door opened a few inches.
它的车牌与金的车相符。波普打开警车的灯和警笛，强迫科迈罗靠边停车。波普走出自己的车，掏出枪。他命令科迈罗的司机下车。司机无视了他。波普又重复了四次命令，但司机纹丝不动。波普再次重复。最后，驾驶座的车门打开了几英寸。
Pope threatened to shoot into the vehicle if the driver didn't exit immediately. The door opened fully and the man behind the wheel began to get out in the strangest way Pope had ever seen. He lay down across both front seats and wriggled out backwards. It was Michael King. He was wearing blue jeans, a camouflage-style t-shirt and black sneakers. He was soaking wet from his waist down. Pope ordered King down on the ground, then cuffed him and patted him down. The soles of his shoes were muddy.
波普威胁说，如果司机不立即下车，他就会向车内开枪。车门完全打开，方向盘后面的男人开始以波普见过的最奇怪的方式下车。他躺在两个前排座椅上，向后蠕动出来。是迈克尔·金。他穿着蓝色牛仔裤、迷彩T恤和黑色运动鞋。他从腰部以下全湿了。波普命令金趴在地上，然后给他戴上手铐并搜身。他的鞋底沾满了泥。
In his pocket was a wallet which contained his driver's license. There was also an empty earplug container and a cell phone which had its battery and SIM card removed. Inside the Camaro, Pope found a blue flashlight, a wooden bed railing and a packet of baby wipes. The battery for the cell phone lay on the passenger side floorboard and a five-gallon gas can sat on the passenger seat. In the back seat was a yellow blanket and a muddy shovel. There was also a small silver ring with a heart on it. Denise Lee wasn't there. After being arrested, Michael King said he would be represented by legal counsel and refused to answer any further questions.
他的口袋里有一个钱包，里面装着他的驾照。还有一个空的耳塞盒和一部拆掉了电池和SIM卡的手机。在科迈罗车内，波普发现了一把蓝色手电筒、一根木制床栏杆和一包婴儿湿巾。手机电池躺在乘客侧的地板上，一个五加仑的汽油桶放在乘客座椅上。后座上有一条黄色毯子和一把沾满泥的铲子。还有一枚带有心形图案的小银戒指。丹妮丝·李不在那里。被捕后，迈克尔·金表示他将由法律顾问代表，并拒绝回答任何进一步的问题。
Harold Muxlow was taken to the interrogation room to see if King would speak candidly with his cousin. Their encounter was filmed. King told Harold that he'd been hijacked while driving and that both he and Denise were kidnapping victims. He'd tried to call 911 but was unable to. The kidnapper blindfolded King so he couldn't see where Denise was left. King subsequently agreed to take the police to an area near his home where he said the carjacking had taken place. A search of the area revealed nothing. Investigators didn't buy King's story for a second.
哈罗德·马克斯洛被带到审讯室，看看金是否会与他的表弟坦诚交谈。他们的相遇被拍摄了下来。金告诉哈罗德，他在开车时被劫持了，他和丹妮丝都是绑架受害者。他试图拨打911，但没能成功。绑架者蒙住了金的眼睛，所以他看不见丹妮丝被留在了哪里。金随后同意带警察去他家附近的一个地方，他说劫车就是在那发生的。对该地区的搜查一无所获。调查人员一点也不相信金的故事。
He was charged with kidnapping and held in protective custody. King's Camaro was moved to a police garage for further examination. Harold Muxlow identified the gas can, flashlight and shovel found in the car as the ones he'd lent his cousin earlier that evening. A palm print on the outside of the driver's side window matched Denise Lee as did several hairs recovered from the back seat. These appeared to have been deliberately pulled from her head. When Denise's husband Nathan was shown the silver ring found in the back seat of King's car, he broke down in tears. It was the ring he'd given Denise for their first of Valentine's Day together. It sat tied on Denise's finger and he knew that the only way it would have come off her hand was if she'd deliberately removed it.
他被控绑架并被拘留在保护性监护下。金的科迈罗被移至警察车库进行进一步检查。哈罗德·马克斯洛确认在车里发现的汽油桶、手电筒和铲子是他那天晚上早些时候借给他表弟的。驾驶座车窗外的一个掌纹与丹妮丝·李相符，从后座回收的几根头发也是如此。这些看起来是被人故意从她头上拔下来的。当丹妮丝的丈夫内森看到在金的车后座发现的那枚银戒指时，他泪流满面。那是他送给丹妮丝的第一个情人节礼物。它戴在丹妮丝的手指上，他知道，除非她故意摘下，否则它是不可能从她手上掉下来的。
Nathan was certain Denise had left it there along with her hairs as evidence for investigators to implicate King in her abduction. A large-scale search and rescue mission for Denise and Lee commenced. It carried on into the following day of Friday, January 18. More than 100 officers, some with police dogs, performed a grid-by-grid search expanding from the location where King was arrested. Some deputies searched on horseback. Others took to kayaks and boats to scour bodies of water. Investigators were hopeful of finding Denise alive. King's Camaro hadn't been bloody.
内森确信丹妮丝把它和她的头发一起留在了那里，作为调查人员指控金绑架她的证据。一场针对丹妮丝·李的大规模搜救行动开始了。它一直持续到第二天，1月18日星期五。100多名警察，其中一些带着警犬，从金被捕的地点开始进行了网格状搜寻。一些副警长骑马搜寻。其他人则乘皮划艇和船只搜寻水域。调查人员希望能活着找到丹妮丝。金的科迈罗上没有血迹。
Northport's police captain reassured the media. There is no evidence of the death of King's car. The police found the body of King's car. King's Camaro hadn't been bloody. Northport's police captain reassured the media. There is no reason to believe Denise is not alive. That night, some canine officers were drawn to an abandoned construction site. It was just off Interstate 75 near the Toledo Blade Boulevard exit.
北港的警察队长向媒体保证：“没有证据表明金的车里有死亡事件。警察找到了金的车。”金的科迈罗上没有血迹。北港的警察队长向媒体保证：“没有理由相信丹妮丝还活着。”那天晚上，一些警犬队被吸引到了一个废弃的建筑工地。它就在75号州际公路旁，靠近托莱多刀锋大道出口。
It was a rural area, not visible from the road. Trees and thickets of palmetto bushes dotted the landscape. Some recently disturbed soil was discovered. Nearby were two small piles of sand that didn't match the rest of the area. On closer inspection, the piles of sand were spotted with blood. An examination indicated there had been blood on the ground. The sand was then shoveled on top to absorb the blood. The next morning in the light of day, a forensics team began excavating the disturbed patch of soil.
这是一个农村地区，从路上看不见。树木和棕榈灌木丛点缀着景观。发现了一些最近被扰动的土壤。附近有两小堆沙子，与该地区的其他部分不符。仔细检查后，发现沙堆上有血迹。检查表明地上有血迹。然后沙子被铲在上面以吸收血液。第二天早上，在光天化日之下，法医小组开始挖掘被扰动的土壤。
Marks in the earth were consistent with it having been dug with a shovel. After digging three feet and one inch into the ground, the team uncovered something lying in a puddle of water. It was Denise Anberle's naked body. Two pieces of duct tape were stuck in her hair. She had been killed with a single gunshot wound near her right eyebrow. A single 9mm shell casing was found in some nearby grass a day or two later. An autopsy would reveal more than 20 internal and external bruises on Denise, consistent with being restrained. There was also evidence that she had been raped.
地上的痕迹与用铲子挖掘的痕迹一致。在地下挖掘了三英尺一英寸后，团队发现了一些躺在水坑里的东西。那是丹妮丝·安布尔·李赤裸的尸体。两块胶带粘在她的头发上。她被右眉附近的一处枪伤杀害。一两天后，在附近的草丛中发现了一个9毫米弹壳。尸检显示丹妮丝身上有20多处内外瘀伤，与被束缚的情况一致。还有证据表明她被强奸了。
A couple of hundred yards away, investigators recovered a shirt belonging to Denise, a bra with a broken strap, a pair of women's underwear in Denise's size and preferred style, and a pair of boxer shorts that were Nathan Lee's. Denise was known to wear them at home as shorts on warm days. The shorts also contained Michael King's DNA. Forensic testing would find traces of Denise's blood on the hood of King's Camaro and on the blanket in the back seat. Within days of finding Denise, her family held a press conference to thank the police and the public for their help. Her father praised Denise's quick thinking from the moment she had been attacked at home, stating,
几百码外，调查人员找回了一件属于丹妮丝的衬衫、一件带断带的胸罩、一条丹妮丝尺码和偏好款式的女式内裤，以及一条内森·李的平角短裤。众所周知，丹妮丝在温暖的日子里会在家里穿它作为短裤。短裤里还含有迈克尔·金的DNA。法医检测在金的科迈罗引擎盖上和后座的毯子上发现了丹妮丝的血迹。在找到丹妮丝后的几天内，她的家人举行了新闻发布会，感谢警察和公众的帮助。她的父亲称赞了丹妮丝从在家中受到攻击那一刻起的快速反应，他说：
She was a strong lady who made sure that her children were safe even though she was faced with adversity. Because of her ability to think on her feet, she was able to provide information to the investigators that will help convict the perpetrator that did this to her. Denise's husband Nathan told the assembled crowd, On behalf of my sons, I want to thank everyone from the bottom of my heart for all their efforts to bring her home. Denise was my soulmate and my best friend, and I will never ever forget about her. My sons will always remember who she was. I will miss her so much. Those who were closest to Michael King were stunned to learn what he was being accused of.
“她是一位坚强的女士，即使面对逆境，她也确保了她的孩子们是安全的。由于她临场应变的能力，她能够向调查人员提供信息，这将有助于定罪对她做出这种事的肇事者。”丹妮丝的丈夫内森告诉聚集的人群：“代表我的儿子们，我要从心底里感谢大家为带她回家所做的一切努力。丹妮丝是我的灵魂伴侣和最好的朋友，我永远不会忘记她。我的儿子们将永远记住她是谁。我会非常想念她。”那些与迈克尔·金最亲近的人得知他被指控的内容时感到震惊。
Fran's family members and former colleagues described him as a nice guy who was happy go lucky. He didn't drink or do drugs, had no history of domestic violence, and was regarded as a hard worker. But he had experienced some misfortune. Originally from Michigan, King was in a sledding accident at age six and suffered a head injury. His family said he changed after that. He suffered headaches which were exacerbated by stress. He struggled at school and had to repeat the first grade. By the time King was eight, he still couldn't write all the letters in the alphabet. A social worker recommended he enter a special education program.
弗兰的家人和前同事形容他是一个快乐、随和的好人。他不喝酒也不吸毒，没有家庭暴力史，被认为是一个勤奋的人。但他经历了一些不幸。金来自密歇根州，6岁时发生了一起雪橇事故，头部受伤。他的家人说他从那以后就变了。他患有头痛，压力会加剧头痛。他在学校表现挣扎，不得不留级一年级。到金8岁时，他仍然无法写出字母表中的所有字母。一名社会工作者建议他参加特殊教育项目。
King also became more impulsive after the accident. When he was 13, he decided to act out a scene from a cartoon that featured a bow and arrow. He nearly killed his brother in the process. At 17, he saw the Texas train saw massacre. Imitating the film's villain Leatherface, King acquired a chainsaw. He began chasing family members with it. His facial expression entirely blank. But King found a vocation in plumbing, got married and had two children. In March 2001, King had been almost 30 years old when he came home from work one day to discover his wife was missing.
事故发生后，金也变得更加冲动。13岁时，他决定表演一个卡通片里的场景，里面有弓和箭。他差点在过程中杀死了他的兄弟。17岁时，他看了《德州电锯杀人狂》。模仿电影里的反派“人皮脸”，金弄到了一把电锯。他开始用它追赶家人。他的面部表情完全空白。但金在管道行业找到了职业，结婚并有了两个孩子。2001年3月，金快30岁时，有一天下班回家发现妻子失踪了。
King went to the local sheriff's department and filed a missing persons report. It soon emerged that his wife was safe and well. She had left King for another man who she'd met on the internet. The couple divorced and King received full-time custody of their son. His wife retained custody of their other child. King purchased the three-bedroom house on Sardinia Avenue and had a series of romantic relationships with different women. Not long after King moved into his house, a feud broke out between him and his next door neighbor. She accused his son of damaging her family's inflatable pool.
金去了当地警长部门并提交了一份失踪人员报告。很快发现他的妻子平安无事。她为了另一个在互联网上认识的男人离开了金。这对夫妇离婚了，金获得了他们儿子的全职监护权。他的妻子保留了他们另一个孩子的监护权。金购买了萨丁尼亚大道上的那栋三居室房子，并与不同的女性有过一系列浪漫关系。金搬进房子后不久，他和隔壁邻居之间就爆发了争执。她指责他的儿子损坏了她家人的充气游泳池。
The neighbor installed a wooden fence between the two properties which upset King. He reportedly took revenge by keying the neighbor's car, slashing its tires, pouring battery acid on her pool cage and throwing eggs at her. The neighbor filed reports with Northport Police. King denied the allegations and there was no evidence against him. Others in the area also disliked King. He was known to deliberately screech his tires loudly as he drove. Some said he would walk around the neighborhood alone at night, peeping into people's windows. King was alleged to have exposed himself to one woman outside a hair salon.
邻居在两处房产之间安装了木栅栏，这让金很不高兴。据报道，他通过划伤邻居的车、割破轮胎、在她的泳池笼上泼电池酸以及向她扔鸡蛋来进行报复。邻居向北港警方提交了报告。金否认了这些指控，也没有证据对他不利。该地区的其他人也不喜欢金。众所周知，他开车时会故意大声刺耳地刹车。有人说他会在晚上独自在社区里走动，窥视人们的窗户。据称，金在一家美发沙龙外向一名女性暴露自己。
Another woman said he had raped her. Neither of these incidents resulted in any charges. For four years, King worked at the same plumbing company until he abruptly left in June 2007. His boss would later tell police King was a habitual liar. He and his 13-year-old son travelled back to Michigan that same month. King's house in Northport sat empty and unoccupied for five years. King's house in Northport sat empty and unoccupied for months. By December 2007, his lack of steady income meant he was facing bankruptcy and foreclosure on his home.
另一名女性说他强奸了她。这些事件都没有导致任何指控。四年来，金在同一家管道公司工作，直到2007年6月突然离开。他的老板后来告诉警察，金是一个惯性说谎者。他和13岁的儿子在同一个月回到了密歇根州。金在北港的房子空置了五个月。金在北港的房子空置了几个月。到2007年12月，他缺乏稳定的收入意味着他面临破产和房屋止赎。
He also broke up with a girlfriend. At the beginning of 2008, he returned to Florida in the hope of sorting out his financial problems and keeping his house. Family members said King began acting oddly around this time, as though he were dazed or even catatonic. He also seemed paranoid. On Sunday, January 13, 2008, less than a week before Denise Amberlee was abducted, other residents on Sardinia Avenue suddenly saw Michael King at his home again. He was with a blonde woman his neighbours didn't recognise. This was likely his new girlfriend, who later told investigators that King's behaviour had been growing even more extreme.
他还和女朋友分手了。2008年初，他回到佛罗里达，希望能解决他的财务问题并保住他的房子。家人说金在这段时间开始表现得很奇怪，好像他处于恍惚甚至紧张性精神症状态。他也显得很偏执。2008年1月13日星期日，在丹妮丝·安布尔·李被绑架前不到一周，萨丁尼亚大道上的其他居民突然又看到了迈克尔·金在家。他和一名邻居不认识的金发女子在一起。这很可能是他的新女朋友，她后来告诉调查人员，金的行为变得越来越极端。
Two days before he took Denise, he told his girlfriend that he thought the neighbours were spying through his windows. He also allegedly owned a 9mm handgun. Investigators couldn't find the gun anywhere, or find any evidence of its existence. It was suspected King had disposed of it at some stage. No ammunition was ever found in his possession either. Despite the lack of a murder weapon, investigators had forensic evidence tying Michael King to Denise Lee, as well as multiple eyewitnesses and circumstantial evidence. King was charged with first degree murder and involuntary sexual battery in addition to the kidnapping charge.
在他带走丹妮丝的两天前，他告诉女朋友，他认为邻居在通过他的窗户监视他。他还据称拥有一把9毫米手枪。调查人员在任何地方都找不到这把枪，也找不到任何证据证明它的存在。人们怀疑金在某个阶段处理掉了它。在他身上也没有发现任何弹药。尽管缺乏凶器，但调查人员有法医证据将迈克尔·金与丹妮丝·李联系起来，以及多名目击者和间接证据。除了绑架指控外，金还被控一级谋杀和非自愿性暴力。
Michael King's trial began in late August 2009, more than 18 months after Denise Amberlee's abduction and murder. The prosecution didn't know how or why King had targeted Denise. When a member of the public reported seeing both Denise and King at the same post office earlier on the day of the attack, it was theorised that King had followed Denise home from there. But this sighting was later debunked as mistaken. A woman who lived in the same street as Denise Lee thought she recognised King as a plumber who'd come to look at her house when it was for sale the previous summer. With no confirmed link between the two, it was posited that King had simply trawled the neighbourhood looking for a victim. For some reason he had chosen Denise and gained access to her home while she was there alone with her two young sons.
迈克尔·金的审判于2009年8月下旬开始，距离丹妮丝·安布尔·李被绑架和谋杀已经过去了18个多月。检方不知道金是如何以及为什么针对丹妮丝的。当一名公众报告说在袭击当天早些时候在同一个邮局看到了丹妮丝和金时，人们推测金是从那里跟踪丹妮丝回家的。但这一目击事件后来被证明是错误的。一位住在丹妮丝·李同一条街上的女人以为她认出金是去年夏天她家出售时来看房的管道工。由于两人之间没有确凿的联系，人们推测金只是在社区里游荡寻找受害者。出于某种原因，他选择了丹妮丝，并在她独自带着两个年幼儿子在家时进入了她的家。
Nathan Lee noted that King's 1995 green Camaro looked very similar to the 1995 green Dodge Avenger he drove. Perhaps when Michael King pulled into their driveway, Denise had mistaken him for her husband. Upon realising she was in danger, she kept her children safe by placing them together in a cot in their bedroom. She then hurriedly closed all the windows and locked the front door. The prosecution had plenty of physical and DNA evidence to back up their case, including the silver ring and strands of hair they believed Denise had deliberately left in King's car. Numerous witnesses who could place Denise in King's car also testified for the prosecution, including King's cousin Harold Muxlow. All of the 911 calls received that night were played for the court, including the one Denise had made herself. Harold Muxlow confirmed that the male voice on Denise's call was Michael King.
内森·李指出，金1995年的绿色科迈罗看起来和他驾驶的1995年绿色道奇复仇者非常相似。也许当迈克尔·金驶入他们的车道时，丹妮丝误把他当成了自己的丈夫。意识到自己处于危险之中后，她把孩子们放在卧室的婴儿床里，以确保他们的安全。随后，她匆忙关上所有窗户并锁上了前门。检方有大量的物证和DNA证据支持他们的案件，包括他们认为丹妮丝故意留在金车里的银戒指和几缕头发。多名能证明丹妮丝在金车里的证人也为检方作证，其中包括金的表弟哈罗德·穆克斯洛。当晚接到的所有911报警电话都在法庭上进行了播放，包括丹妮丝自己打的那通。哈罗德·穆克斯洛证实，丹妮丝通话中出现的男性声音就是迈克尔·金。
The defence didn't call any witnesses, instead they tried to implicate a friend of King's named Robert Salvador. Police initially thought Robert was King's accomplice after they learnt the two were together shortly before Denise lays abduction. They had gone to a gun range that morning to practise target shooting. King brought along a 9mm handgun while Robert supplied the ammunition. They finished at 1pm, around 90 minutes before Denise was taken. Robert had alibis confirming that he wasn't with King during or after her abduction. The defence attempted to place the pair together when Denise was killed and accused Robert of executing her. Robert vehemently denied this.
辩方没有传唤任何证人，而是试图牵连金的一位名叫罗伯特·萨尔瓦多的朋友。警方最初认为罗伯特是金的同伙，因为他们得知两人在丹妮丝被绑架前不久曾在一起。那天早上他们去了一个射击场练习打靶。金带了一把9毫米手枪，而罗伯特提供了弹药。他们在下午1点结束，大约在丹妮丝被带走前90分钟。罗伯特有不在场证明，证实他在丹妮丝被绑架期间或之后并没有和金在一起。辩方试图将两人在丹妮丝遇害时联系在一起，并指控罗伯特是行凶者。罗伯特对此予以强烈否认。
The judge subsequently instructed the jury to dismiss several of these questions, stating, There is no basis in fact from the evidence for the asking of these questions. The jury deliberated for two hours before reaching a verdict. Guilty on all counts. Denise's husband, parents, her 20 year old sister and 15 year old brother all cried as it was delivered. King stared straight ahead. The jury also recommended he receive a death sentence. It was a sentence Denise's family were in favour of.
法官随后指示陪审团驳回其中几个问题，称：“这些问题的提出在证据基础上没有任何事实依据。”陪审团经过两个小时的审议后达成裁决：所有罪名成立。丹妮丝的丈夫、父母、20岁的姐姐和15岁的弟弟在宣判时都哭了。金直视前方。陪审团还建议判处他死刑。这是丹妮丝家人所支持的判决。
Nathan Lee told the Tampa Tribune, quote, One thing that really bothers me is he can think about Denise whenever he wants to. I don't want him to have those memories. I want him gone. A penalty phase was held to determine whether King was competent to receive a death sentence. The defence argued that the sledding accident he'd suffered as a six year old caused permanent brain damage. A psychiatrist who performed a scan on King said his frontal lobe showed indications of abnormal activity consistent with a traumatic brain injury. He explained that individuals with frontal lobe injuries can sometimes exhibit poor judgement, risk taking behaviour and poor impulse control.
内森·李告诉《坦帕论坛报》：“有一件事真的很困扰我，那就是他想什么时候想起丹妮丝就可以什么时候想起。我不希望他拥有那些记忆。我希望他消失。”法庭举行了量刑阶段听证会，以确定金是否有能力接受死刑判决。辩方辩称，他六岁时遭受的雪橇事故导致了永久性脑损伤。一位对金进行扫描的精神科医生表示，他的额叶显示出与创伤性脑损伤一致的异常活动迹象。他解释说，额叶受伤的人有时会表现出判断力差、冒险行为和冲动控制能力差的问题。
King's siblings testified about some of his dangerous behaviour as an adolescent. The psychiatrist also said that a recent verbal IQ score King had taken placed him in the borderline range of having an intellectual disability. The prosecution's expert psychologist also had King take an IQ test. While his results also placed King in the borderline range, he counted that King's ability to concentrate and comprehend was stronger than the results indicated. The trial judge ruled that King was competent and sentenced him to death by lethal injection for the murder of Denise Amber Lee. King later appealed his conviction but it was upheld. As of late 2022 he remains on death row in Florida. The conviction of Michael King wasn't the end of the Denise Amber Lee case.
金的兄弟姐妹作证说他青少年时期有一些危险行为。精神科医生还表示，金最近进行的言语智商测试得分处于智力残疾的边缘范围。检方的专家心理学家也让金参加了智商测试。虽然结果也显示金处于边缘范围，但他反驳说，金的专注和理解能力比结果显示的要强。审判法官裁定金具有完全行为能力，并因谋杀丹妮丝·安珀·李判处他注射死刑。金后来对定罪提出上诉，但被驳回。截至2022年底，他仍被关押在佛罗里达州的死囚牢房中。迈克尔·金的定罪并不是丹妮丝·安珀·李案件的终结。
Many questions remained as to whether she could have been saved given the number of 911 calls received as the crime was taking place. Particularly significant was the 911 call from witness Jane Kowalski. She provided real-time updates to emergency dispatch while attempting to follow King's Camaro along US Highway 41. She also gave the dispatcher her contact information in case anything further was required. Jane didn't hear back from law enforcement after making her call. The following day she saw news footage of Michael King's arrest. She recognized him immediately as the driver of the Camaro she'd seen. At the time, Jane believed she was witnessing a child abduction.
关于在犯罪发生时接到如此多911报警电话的情况下，她是否本可以获救，仍存在许多疑问。其中特别重要的是目击者简·科瓦尔斯基打来的911电话。她在试图沿着41号美国国道追踪金的科迈罗时，向紧急调度员提供了实时更新。她还向调度员提供了自己的联系方式，以防需要进一步的信息。简在打完电话后没有收到执法部门的回复。第二天，她看到了迈克尔·金被捕的新闻片段。她立刻认出他就是她看到的科迈罗的司机。当时，简以为自己目睹了一起儿童绑架案。
It wasn't until then she discovered King had actually taken a grown woman. Jane told the television program Dateline of her distress upon realizing the crime had been real. She decided to call the North Port Police Department telling them, I'm the 911 caller who called in. Do you need any more information from me? The North Port Police were baffled. They had no idea what Jane was referring to and had no record of her call. Because of Jane's location when she rang, her call had been routed to neighboring Charlotte County, not Sarasota County where North Port was situated.
直到那时她才发现金实际上带走的是一名成年女性。简在电视节目《日界线》中讲述了她在意识到犯罪是真实发生时的痛苦。她决定致电北港警察局，告诉他们：“我是那个打911报警的人。你们还需要我提供更多信息吗？”北港警方感到困惑。他们根本不知道简在说什么，也没有她报警的记录。由于简拨打电话时所处的位置，她的电话被转接到了邻近的夏洛特县，而不是北港所在的萨拉索塔县。
For some reason, Charlotte County Sheriff's Department, the same department that Denise's father worked for, had failed to pass the message along. An internal investigation revealed that the 911 operator who'd taken the call realized it was related to the Denise Amperley case and had been urgent. However, she hadn't entered the information into a computer database as per protocol. Instead, she'd called it out to police dispatchers who sat across the aisle from her and passed over a handwritten note. They heard her but hadn't sent the tip out due to the particularly chaotic circumstances of that night. One dispatcher thought she couldn't send it out due to mistakenly thinking her radio wasn't working.
出于某种原因，夏洛特县治安官部门——也就是丹妮丝父亲工作的同一个部门——未能传递这条信息。内部调查显示，接听电话的911接线员意识到这与丹妮丝·安珀·李案有关，而且情况紧急。然而，她并没有按照规定将信息输入计算机数据库。相反，她把它喊给了坐在她过道对面的警察调度员，并递过一张手写纸条。他们听到了她的喊话，但由于当晚情况特别混乱，没有发出警报。一名调度员认为她无法发出警报，因为她错误地以为自己的无线电坏了。
Others assumed their colleagues passed it along. Jane Kowalski's crucial information had simply slipped through the cracks. At the time, multiple sheriff's deputies had been stationed along the road that Michael King was driving along while Denise was still alive in the back seat. One deputy realized he had likely been stationed at the Toledo Blade Boulevard intersection at 6.35pm, around the same time that King drove through it. Without the tip-off being passed along, he hadn't noticed King's car. The investigation led to the call operator requesting a voluntary demotion to a desk clerk position after 15 years in the job. Four call operators had to undergo remedial training. Two dispatchers were suspended for failing to send out patrol cars in response to the call.
其他人则以为同事已经传达了。简·科瓦尔斯基的关键信息就这样被遗漏了。当时，多名治安官副手就驻扎在迈克尔·金驾驶的道路沿线，而丹妮丝当时还活着，就在后座上。一名副手意识到他当时很可能就在下午6点35分驻扎在托莱多刀锋大道交叉口，大约就在金开车经过的时间。由于没有收到提示，他没有注意到金的车。调查导致该接线员在工作15年后主动申请降职为文员。四名接线员不得不接受补救培训。两名调度员因未能响应报警电话派出巡逻车而被停职。
One for 60 hours and the other for 36. While the Charlotte County Sheriff publicly announced the suspensions, he did not apologize for the errors. Denise's father, Rick Goff, has struggled with the knowledge that such a mistake was made by the same department he'd spent 25 years working for. She's beating on the window so hard and screaming trying to get help, which is the smart thing to do because by that time she knows she probably wasn't coming back, he told television program Dateline. As far as I'm concerned, we blew it. And I say we, because I'm part of that sheriff's office. Rick began to lobby for improved training for 911 call takers, which led to the Denise Amberley Act being signed into Florida law. The Act provides for voluntary training for emergency line operators. Rick and other members of Denise's family continue to advocate for mandatory training and certification for all 911 operators.
一人被停职60小时，另一人被停职36小时。虽然夏洛特县治安官公开宣布了停职决定，但他并没有为这些错误道歉。丹妮丝的父亲里克·戈夫一直为这样一个事实感到痛苦：这个错误竟然是由他工作了25年的同一个部门犯下的。他告诉电视节目《日界线》：“她当时拼命拍打窗户并尖叫着寻求帮助，这是明智的做法，因为那时她知道自己可能回不来了。就我而言，我们搞砸了。我说‘我们’，是因为我也是治安官办公室的一员。”里克开始游说改进911接线员的培训，这促使《丹妮丝·安珀·李法案》被签署成为佛罗里达州法律。该法案规定为紧急线路接线员提供自愿培训。里克和丹妮丝家人的其他成员继续倡导对所有911接线员进行强制性培训和认证。
Nathan Lee told Dateline that if Janka Wolskie's information had been passed on, quote, There's not a doubt in my mind Denise would still be here. Not a doubt in my mind. In the wake of his wife's murder, Nathan found it difficult to return to his job as a meter reader. The position gave him too much time to walk and think. He found the constant rumination painful. Six months after his wife's death, Nathan established the Denise Amberley Foundation to advocate for improvements to the 911 system. The nonprofit was a way to create some good for his family's enormous loss by using their tragedy to impart valuable lessons. Nathan has traveled all over the United States to share Denise's story with call takers. Speaking on 911 reform is now his full-time career.
内森·李告诉《日界线》，如果简·科瓦尔斯基的信息被传达出去，“我毫不怀疑丹妮丝现在还会在这里。我对此深信不疑。”在妻子遇害后，内森发现很难回到他担任抄表员的工作岗位。这份工作给了他太多走路和思考的时间。他发现不断的沉思非常痛苦。在妻子去世六个月后，内森成立了丹妮丝·安珀·李基金会，以倡导改进911系统。这个非营利组织是一种通过利用他们的悲剧来传授宝贵经验，从而为他家人的巨大损失创造一些积极意义的方式。内森走遍了美国各地，与接线员分享丹妮丝的故事。现在，就911改革进行演讲已成为他的全职工作。
In 2008, Nathan told the St. Petersburg Times that he believed his wife's fierce fight for survival was due to her desire to be reunited with their sons. Quote, She had a lot of reason to get out of that car. I know the main thing on her mind was getting to see those kids again. Although he believes it is a blessing that their sons were too young to remember the circumstances surrounding their mother's death, it was painful knowing that they wouldn't remember her either. Over the years, he has taken them to visit Denise's grave and played home movies featuring her for them. Nathan has been able to take some comfort in knowing their mother will always be there in some way, telling Dateline producers, I'm not worried about them. They've got part of Denise in them, and that's the most comforting thing I can think about. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
2008年，内森告诉《圣彼得堡时报》，他相信妻子为生存而进行的激烈斗争是因为她渴望与儿子们团聚。“她有很多理由逃出那辆车。我知道她脑子里想的最主要的事情就是再次见到那些孩子。”虽然他认为儿子们太小而不记得母亲去世时的情景是一种福气，但知道他们也不会记得她本人，这让他感到痛苦。多年来，他一直带他们去祭扫丹妮丝的墓，并为他们播放她出镜的家庭录像。内森在得知母亲会以某种方式永远陪伴在他们身边时感到了一些安慰，他告诉《日界线》的制片人：“我不担心他们。他们身上有丹妮丝的一部分，这是我能想到的最令人欣慰的事情。”本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。